hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in Section 2 of his inquiry concerning
the human understanding David Hume
brings up an interesting thought
experiment about colors and the ideas
that we have in our mind in our capacity
a productive capacity of our imagination
to supply what sensation would not have
had and before we launch into examining
that example that he provides and
considering what its implications are we
should think about the the general
principle that he's trying to use this
to to illustrate so this is in his
discussion about where our ideas come
from they come from our impressions
originally certainly the ones that that
have to do with sense do so but also
those that that stem from you could say
our passions are internal States so he
says that if it happened from a defect
of the organ that a person is not
susceptible of any species of sensation
any type of sensation we always find
that there is little susceptible to the
correspondent idea because remember
ideas other than the ones that we you
know come compound and compose through
the imagination are copies of our
original impressions or perceptions
through the senses or through our
passions so he says a blind person for
example can form no notion of colors a
deaf person none of sounds but restore
to either of them
the sense in which they're deficient by
opening this new Inlet for their
sensations you also open an inlet for
the ideas and then they find no
difficulty in conceiving these objects
the whole range of that that sense he
says that it's similar with with
particular objects the case is the same
if the object proper for exciting any
sensation has never been applied to the
organ a laplander person then the high
north and Finland or an African has no
notion of the relish of wine now of
course humans a little bit off base when
it comes to that and he says although
there are a few or no instances of a
like deficiency in the mind when a
person has never felt or is wholly
incapable of a sentiment or a passion
that belongs to the species we find the
same observation to take place in a less
degree so a man of mild manners can form
no ID and no effective idea of
inveterate revenge or cruelty or ID he
lacks the the original passion that then
could give rise to the idea in their
mind nor can a selfish heart easily
conceive the heights of friendship and
generosity they can know the word they
can have a really vague concept that
people think this is important but they
can't actually do anything with it and
another great example of this or people
who don't feel fear one person who is a
particularly aggressive man when shown
pictures of people showing fear on their
face he said that's the face people make
before I hurt them
he couldn't conceive of what fear was
was actually like interestingly some of
those people who in most cases don't
feel fear have been shown by by some
experiments to have the possibility of
having it in do
by subjecting them to near-drowning
and in that case it winds up being
almost unmanageable so going on with
this he says that it's readily allowed
other beings may possess many senses of
which we can have no conception because
the ideas of them have never been
introduced to us in the only manner by
which an idea can have access to the
mind that is by the actual feeling and
sensation so that what is the general
rule here if we don't have a sense
perception an impression of it or a
impression by having a passion or
sentiment then we can't have the
corresponding idea
now Hume says that's usually the case
but we can imagine a case where things
turn out differently and here's where we
get this very interesting exception
about the missing shade of blue he says
that I believe it will readily be
allowed that the several distinct ideas
of color which entered by the eye or the
sound which are conveyed by the ear are
really different from each other though
at the same time resembling each other
so what does he mean they're different
shades of for example like the white on
the chalkboard right if you were to look
at these track marks very carefully or
the gray of the chalkboard you would
notice that they're different from each
other if you blew it up in an image you
could look at the pixels and you could
like pick out each one as having a
different color profile right so he says
that this be this is true of different
colors it must be no less so of the
different shades of the same color so
humans gonna consider blue why blue
that's a nice primary color easy to see
contrast with you don't have the problem
of red-green color blindness or any of
that sort of stuff so we've got blue now
think to yourself of your own
experiences with all the different
shades of blue right imagine that like
you're going to the hardware store and
picking out some paint with those color
pattern strips that you can see and
they've got all the different shade
so Hume says let's imagine to ourself
that we have a person who has enjoyed
his sight for 30 years and as Hume says
he is perfectly acquainted with all the
different shades of blue except for one
which this person has never come across
now perfectly acquainted means that
they've had many experiences of these
these shades of blue they've got plenty
of impressions those impressions have
given a rise to ideas let's even go a
little bit further than Hume and say
this person has you know a really good
memory and they can lay out all these
different shades in relation to each
other so he says let all the different
shades of that color except that single
one be placed in front of this person
descending gradually from the deepest
the darkest almost black to the lightest
now here's where it gets really
interesting Hume says this person is
actually going to perceive a blank in
the place where that missing shade ought
to be that seems rather dubious if we
understand it in terms of an literally a
blank spot because we've got these color
tiles all laid out in relation to each
other but the person could like spread
them all part from each other and say
there's something missing here I think
that's more or less what Hume has in
mind when he says perceives a blank he
perceives that there's something missing
there Wow because he's sensible of the
greater contrast between the two blues
between which this missing shade of blue
ought to be so he's sensible of a lack
of a shade of blue that should be right
in between those two how is he sensible
of that well he's looking at this entire
gradation and he sees that something is
not right something is missing there's
more of a leap from one
discreet blue to the next discreet blue
now here's where it gets important from
a human perspective up until this point
it's just kind of an interesting you
know coincidence and we can do replicate
this with other things right tastes
sounds you know odors all sorts of other
things as well right touch perhaps
person has never experienced a certain
type of heat right can that person
through the force of their imagination
there's this power that we have he says
would it be possible for that person
from their own imagination to supply
this deficiency and raise up to himself
the idea of that particular shade though
it had never been conveyed to him by his
senses then Hume says I think that
everyone would agree or their their few
but will be of the opinion that he can
and now what is the implication of this
Hume says this is a proof that the
simple ideas are not in every instance
derive from the correspondent
impressions so it's possible that the
general rule that Hume lays out that all
of our ideas of the mind are derived
from the impressions we originally have
it's possible that there are important
exceptions to that but how important are
these exceptions they're actually not
that important Hume says this serves as
a proof the simple ideas are not always
derived from it though this instance is
so singular that it is scarcely worth
our observing you might say well why did
you observe it then Hume and does not
merit that for it alone we should alter
our general maxim we can say that our
general maxim is in general correct
our ideas are derived from our
impressions but there is the possibility
that in rare case
is where a person already has a very
well-developed set of sensory
experiences to work with they can use
their productive Faculty of imagination
to supply what is missing notice that
this has to be something that actually
is missing this is not about imagining a
shade of blue that's not within the blue
spectrum some some new shade of blue
that doesn't exist instead it has to do
with one that we know is missing for
this person and we could say the same
thing about flavors you know a person
tries out a bunch of different spicy
peppers and they you know they've got a
really spicy one here and a mildly spicy
one here and that's all they've ever
tasted and then they've tasted bland
things and they've tasted super spicy
things they could supply the well kind
of in the middle taste or think about
beers right the bitterness of hops you
could well imagine to yourself what a
hop in between this one and this one is
like can't you or in terms of sweetness
or things like that but you have to have
a frame of reference already well
developed in order to make this work and
we could also say how do we actually
know that that person has in their mind
the corresponding idea it's not like we
can carve their head open and look
inside and see the missing shade of blue
so that is what's going on with this
interesting exception about the missing
and then supplied through the
imagination shade of blue
you